He had it, he still couldn’t
believe that he had it.
Very few professional thieves managed to steal
something so valuable right from under the nose
of the SCP Foundation, and even fewer lived to
tell anyone about it. Kasdan gripped the bag in
one hand, holding on so tightly his knuckles felt
like they might split. He was drenched in nervous
sweat, the clamminess of his palms leaving
an imprint on the material of the duffel bag.
Its precious contents moved around loosely; every
time it jostled and knocked against him, Kasdan
had to fight the urge to unzip the bag, just to
remind himself this was all actually happening.
But he resisted, he knew the mask wanted not
only to be seen but to be heard as well. The
earpiece his client had provided was doing its
job, keeping the whispers at bay, dampening
the telepathic aura enough to ensure that Kasdan
retained control over his own faculties. The bag,
he’d been told, would also hopefully dampen
the powers of the mask’s corrosive fluid.
He’d been prepped extensively for this job,
more than any other in his long and storied
criminal career. It had taken months of planning,
staking out the home of a Foundation researcher,
stealing his access card, and slipping into
the heavily-guarded facility undetected.
As if that hadn’t been hard enough, he
then had to find the right containment
cell containing what he’d been hired to steal.
Just like any heist, the timing was everything.
He had to make sure he was there on the exact day
the glass container housing his target was due to
be replaced thanks to corrosion damage, having
been gradually melted and worn away over time.
At an intensely precise moment on precisely
the right day, Kasdan had to enter the cell,
and sedate not only the research staff that
had come to swap out the glass container
but the armed guards posted outside, too. Then,
it was just a case of slipping on the specialized
gloves he’d been issued, grabbing the mask, and
stashing it in the bag with protective lining to
stop it from being corroded during transit.
All things considered, Kasdan had been
doing pretty well, given the circumstances.
That was until he heard the blare of alarms
ringing out. His heart, which had already been
drumming away in his chest through sheer nerves,
now began beating so fast it threatened to crack
his ribs. Panic shot through his entire system,
and at that moment, all sense of rationality
was dropped faster than a lead balloon.
Any further attempts at subterfuge were pointless,
why keep hiding? Surely the alarms were for him,
Kasdan thought, and immediately started running,
losing all cover. He barged past a pair
of Foundation researchers in lab coats,
knocking them both to the ground; a storm
of paper files that they’d been carrying
were hurled up into the air, a temporary
smokescreen to cover Kasdan’s panicked escape.
One foot launching past the other, he barrelled
down the facility’s corridors, the same way he’d
come in. If he was quick, he might make it
before they sealed the exits and trapped him
inside. The chances were slim, and Kasdan knew it,
but he was left with no other choice apart from
letting the SCP Foundation catch him, hauling
him off to God-knows-where for interrogation.
He barrelled past more Foundation staff,
some of them holding their hands out to
try and stop him as they figured out what the
alarms were for and why Kasdan was running.
Shoving one out of the way, he felt something
snag at the lab coat he’d worn as a disguise.
One of the researchers had him!
Kicking a leg back, Kasdan clipped the man’s knee
and whipped himself free of the coat, not letting
them stop him from running. He was close now,
so close to the door he’d come in through; if he
could just pass this corner, he’d be home free.
The clomp of multiple heavy, steel-toed
tactical boots came rushing through the
entrance to meet him. A squad of men – one
of the Foundation’s infamous Mobile Task
Forces – were hurtling towards Kasdan like
a tidal wave wearing all-black combat gear.
He skidded as he tried to turn back the way he’d
come, stumbling over his feet as he was chased by
the sound of angry shouts commanding him to
freeze, drop the bag and get on the ground.
Kasdan dared not look over his shoulder,
catching hints of the oncoming MTF agents
in his peripheral vision, compelling him to
keep running. But with no idea where to go,
and four heavily-armed operatives clipping at
his heels, there was little hope of escaping now.
A powerful, weighty force struck Kasdan’s back,
knocking the air out of his lungs as it pushed
him over and kept him pinned to the floor. He
could barely move as the agent tackled him,
gasping as he desperately tried to pull his breath
back. The rest of the squad gathered around him,
all yelling and warning him not to
move. But there was another sound…
no, another voice, drowning out the soldiers.
The earpiece, the one thing keeping his mind
safe. It was gone, it must’ve fallen out when he
hit the ground… and now, the mask could get in.
The whispering was unintelligible, nonsense
really; Kasdan couldn’t clearly make out what
it was saying. He only knew it had quickly become
the only thing he could hear, and how it made him
feel. He had to put the mask on. It was such a
strong compulsion, it felt like so much more than
a want, a desire to wear it; it was a need.
The bag was so close, dropped to the floor
when he had been tackled. If he could
just reach it and tear the zipper open,
he’d have the mask in his hands.
Rolling over, Kasdan lashed out at the MTF
operative, catching him by surprise as his fist
connected with the man’s balaclava-covered face.
The agent was stunned, lifting some of his
weight that had been pinning the thief down,
just enough for Kasdan to free his other
hand. Another pair of agents tried to hold
his flailing arms to the ground, only for him to
reach up and pull one of them face-first into the
concrete floor with a bloody crunch. With every
ounce of strength that he could muster, Kasdan
moved like a man possessed, hurling the agent on
his other arm into the first who had tackled him.
Slipping out from underneath the crumpled agents,
he crawled on his stomach as far and as fast as he
could. Kasdan desperately scrabbled for the duffel
bag. It was so close, a mere few inches away,
his fingertips brushing up against it
as he reached. But he couldn’t grab it,
as much as he felt that overwhelming need to. His
feet were still buried under the weight of the MTF
operators and their gear, stopping him from
reaching any further… until one of the agents
moved, just enough to free Kasdan’s foot.
Everything seemed to move in slow motion. The
MTF soldiers were reaching out to pull Kasdan off
the floor, as his hands shot forward and tightly
gripped the straps of his bag. He could feel hands
wrapped in tactical gloves gripping at his shirt;
in the same instant, he wrenched the bag towards
him and pulled down the zipper. He had to
get to what was inside, even if it killed him.
He barely noticed his earpiece getting crunched
under the heavy combat boot of one of the agents.
Instead, he was inhaling fumes from the interior
of the bag, its specialized inner lining already
melting thanks to the viscous black substance
secreting from the mask. Kasdan didn’t even
register the pain in his hands when he reached
inside, the secretion corroding his bare skin
as he retrieved what he’d been hired to steal,
what he now so desperately needed to put
on his face: SCP-035, the Possessive Mask.
Time felt like it had ground to a halt, freezing
everyone. Kasdan stared for a split second at
the white porcelain surface of the mask. It
felt like it was glaring hatefully at him,
thanks to its exaggerated tragedy grimace.
It was almost as if it disproved of Kasdan,
as if he was somehow unworthy of it. But
holding it in his hands, the compulsion to
put on SCP-035 was now so unbearable. Oblivious to
the Foundation agents around him, who were trying
in vain to restrain him again, Kasdan tipped his
face into the mask… and everything went black.
It was like being half asleep, his
awareness of certain things stripped away.
Things like the pain searing his face, a gradual,
acidic burning that was eating away at his flesh,
corroding his body. And yet, Kasdan could still
feel occasional sensations. Tremors running
up his arms as his fists made contact with
something, then pulled back and struck again,
leaving behind something wet on his knuckles.
But he couldn’t see, all around him was shrouded
in darkness. He knew his body was moving,
maybe even walking, taking him somewhere,
but he had no clue where, and no control anymore.
It was like someone… something else had pushed
his mind out of the driver’s seat, and now
had both its corruptive hands on the wheel.
His mind was lost in the
blackness. Shut down. Gone.
It was only when he came back around that Kasdan
felt the sheer, unrelenting agony fully wash
over him. The mask was off again, leaving him a
scorched, screaming mess. He was laying on the
floor of another containment cell. This one was
different from the one he’d stolen SCP-035 from,
it was less heavily guarded, minimal security.
It might not even have been in the same facility.
Kasdan had no idea how long he’d been
wearing the mask for. All he knew,
apart from the intense pain of the corrosive
black sludge breaking his body down, and the
bloodstains on his hands and clothes, was that he
wasn’t alone… someone else was in there with him.
Kasdan didn’t know the strangest part of all
this. He should be dead; No, he was dead.
Much like Dr. Bright’s medallion, the Possessive
Mask typically wipes the human mind like Oxiclean.
If he was back, it meant somebody brought
him back. Somebody with truly great power…
Craning his head up, he caught sight of the
cell’s only other occupant. Even squinting
through his stinging eyes, Kasdan couldn’t
make out exactly where the other man was from,
only that he was much older. He was looking
down at Kasdan writhing on the floor;
there was something almost… sad lingering in his
eyes. There was a kind of sympathy behind them,
not just from looking at someone with such
severe injuries, but an almost apologetic gaze,
like he was sorry that the pain
even existed in the first place.
“Glad to see you’re back, my son,” the old
man said. “It’s been a while since I’ve
needed to pull someone back from that deep in the
darkness. I was worried I’d be a little rusty…”
The old man gently reached a hand out towards him…
and took Kasdan’s pain away. He didn’t heal him,
not fully, just hit ‘pause’ on his wounds.
But before he could thank the kind stranger,
the mask started whispering again. Only
this time, it was calling to the old man.
No longer hurting but still reeling from what
SCP-035 had done to him, Kasdan tried to stop
the man, calling with a rasping voice, begging
him not to listen to the Possessive Mask’s call.
He didn’t seem as spellbound as Kasdan had
been, in fact, the old man almost just looked
like he was going through the motions. Pacing
over to where SCP-035 lay on the cell floor,
picking it up and, just like Kasdan had done,
he lifted the porcelain mask over his wrinkled,
wizened face. Helpless, unable to do
anything other than watch on in horror,
Kasdan couldn’t help but notice the tragic frown
carved onto the surface of SCP-035 had shifted;
now, it was a wide, gaping smile, a comedic
grin with nothing but ill intent behind it.
While he had no idea who the old man was,
some swirling, sickening feeling in the pit
of Kasdan’s stomach told him nothing good could
come from putting that twisted mask over another
anomalous being. If he had only known that
SCP-343 was colloquially nicknamed ‘God’ by
the Foundation’s staff, and was widely believed
to be the sole creator of the entire universe,
then Kasdan would have used all his strength
to pull the mask off the old man’s face and
smash it to pieces. But it was already too late.
The very second the Possessive Mask slipped over
SCP-343’s face, the ground shook violently,
like the very Earth itself was afraid of what
had just happened. Still watching from the cell
floor, Kasdan looked at this combined creature.
It stood still for a moment,
slowly breathing through the mask,
before it lifted its hands and appeared to
examine them. The comedy smile on SCP-035 made
it seem like the mask itself was looking with
a warped sense of glee at its new host body.
More of the same black goo was being
secreted out from beneath the mask,
drops of it were rolling off the old man’s
shoulders. They landed on the cell floor, melting
tiny, burning holes as the substance dripped down
through the concrete and steel of the facility.
His body being puppeteered by the mask on his
face, the old man wiped a smear of the sludge away
with his hand, looking at it in his fingers. It
wasn’t melting him the same way it had to Kasdan;
usually, the corrosive secretion that SCP-035
naturally produced proved to be its weakness,
melting the bodies of its human
hosts and eventually destroying them,
leaving the mask without a form to pilot. SCP-343,
on the other hand, was only humanoid in shape,
and far beyond any mortal being that
the Possessive Mask had ever enthralled.
The combined being, corruptive mask and omnipotent
god, raised its hands high, like a conductor
before an orchestra. From the spot he lay in,
Kasdan watched in horror as every member of staff
in the facility was pulled up through the floor,
or dragged screaming through the walls, piping
and brickwork tearing through them. This was a
minimum-security Foundation wing, far more relaxed
with only a handful of staff and a light force of
guards. Still, to SCP-035, it didn’t matter how
many there were. It was enough to make a start.
The wrinkly hands of its new host clenched
sharply; the Foundation staff, all
suspended in mid-air, suddenly exploded.
Each one of them, every researcher and
guard, erupted into a fireball, burning
white-hot like heated metal, before fizzling out.
There was nothing left, no scraps of clothing,
no remains, they just… weren’t.
If it wanted to, SCP-035 would have thrown its
head back and laughed maniacally. In some strange
way, Kasdan thought that might have been better.
Instead, it was silent, the mask’s wide, soulless
grin conveying its twisted delight well enough.
It turned to face the wall, thick
layers of concrete standing between it
and the outside world, and began stepping forward,
so completely casually that it was unnerving.
With the first step, the walls of the cell
surrounding the SCP-035 and SCP-343 hybrid,
as well as Kasdan, began to crumble away. With
the second, the corridor outside did the same,
falling apart without any exertion
of effort from the masked god.
Each and every step further, more of the
building around them was chipped away,
carving a path through rooms and research
stations towards the edge of the site.
It was as though the concrete and brickwork,
the dense, heavy materials that constructed
the facility suddenly had the consistency of
wet sand; and SCP-035 and its new host were the
tides coming in, washing away all in their path.
No longer in pain, but his body distorted beyond
repair, Kasdan forced himself up off the ground
at last. Weakly, he limped after the creature,
thinking in vain he had any chance to stand
against a being with the unbridled power of a god
and the infinite cruelty and
malice of the Possessive Mask.
If he could just get close enough, Kasdan
thought, he could tear the mask away,
freeing the old man. He wouldn’t be able to
stop himself from putting it on a second time,
but perhaps it was better that Kasdan wore
it, and let its black ooze melt him down.
At least the wise, kindly old man would be able to
get far enough away from SCP-035’s influence, and
Kasdan could, at least in part, put this right.
After all, he’d stolen the mask from the
Foundation, this all started with him.
As the hybrid reached the farthest wall,
the barrier turned to glass and shattered. The
combined monster looked out over the waiting,
helpless world. Through SCP-343, the Possessive
Mask had control over chaos and creation alike,
and nothing on Earth that could challenge
it. Not the Foundation, not humanity,
not even other anomalies. Lifting its still,
lifeless, grinning mask upwards, the sky darkened,
the deafening boom of thunder ringing out above.
Forked bolts of deep orange lightning cracked
across the atmosphere, as what
was left of the Foundation
facility dissolved behind the masked god.
Though it was facing out towards a world that
would soon crumble as easily as this building, the
creature could see everything, far beyond where
it stood, the lives of billions upon billions.
All at once, it watched plants grow while others
wilted, animals born only to die, humans
living out their ritualistic existences,
each of them gradually heading for the same fate.
And through all of that, it saw a hand, trembling
behind it, reaching for its mask: Kasdan.
He was so close, fingertips just about to brush
the porcelain surface of SCP-035. When suddenly
the mask, and the old man wearing it, were gone.
Kasdan turned around in confusion, only
to find it was now standing behind him.
It reached out one of the wrinkled, bony old
hands and touched a single finger on his forehead.
Kasdan blinked, and he was back. Back before the
heist, before any of the wanton devastation had
begun. He recognized the room he was in,
and sat in the very same place where his
mysterious benefactor had approached him with a
seemingly impossible job: to steal a mask from
the SCP Foundation. Sure enough, sitting across
the table, obscured by shadow was the client.
But behind his eyes, Kasdan was trapped, helpless
as he watched himself live out the same events
that had led to the mask being placed on the face
of God. He couldn’t change the course of history,
couldn’t avert the apocalypse that was
already happening. All he could do was watch,
his heart sinking as his client pushed a
file across the table, opening it to reveal
a photograph of his target, the thing he wanted
Kasdan to steal: SCP-035, the Possessive Mask.
And meanwhile, back in the new hell of its own
creation, the mask was having some real fun…
Now go and check out “SCP-035 THE POSSESSIVE
MASK” and “SCP-343 GOD” to learn even more
about this pair of anomalies, and pray that
nobody ever has the chance to combine them.